about whitey bulger America's Most
Wanted gangster and the manhunt that
brought him to justice this is about an
hour
my name's Pam Sutherland we'd like to
thank the City of Tucson for sponsoring
this venue we also thank Rob and Judy
Wilson for sponsoring this session the
presentation will last one hour
including questions and answers so
please hold your questions to the end at
the conclusion of the session the
author's will go to a signing area to
meet you and autograph their books out
of respect for the authors and your
fellow audience members please turn off
your cell phones now so everybody take a
second look at your cell phone is it off
so we have two wonderful Boston Globe
colonists here
Kevin Cullen and Shelley Murphy they are
currently columnist for the Boston Globe
and Kevin is working on his column for
Tuesday's paper as you know they're the
authors of this book on whitey bulger
kevin has been a reporter for the globe
since 1985 in 2003 he was part of the
investigative team that won the Pulitzer
for coverage of the Catholic Church sex
abuse scandal he went to the Trinity
University in Dublin he is from Malden
and he covered the conflict in Northern
Ireland Shelley Murphy is also a
reporter at the Boston Globe has worked
there for 21 years she's covered
organized crime for much of that time
she was previously at the Boston Herald
she's run a poke award and she's from
Dorchester and welcome to Tucson YouTube
so just the book actually was one of the
finalist for the National Book Critics
Circle Award so congratulations on that
and can you tell us why you started
following this story and give us a
little bit of background on it well
first of all Shelley and I would like to
thank everybody associated with the Book
Festival for having us here we've been
here for 22 hours that have already
fallen in love with this town and it
must be fate that but whitey is about
ten or eleven miles from here right now
in your penitentiary and we asked him if
he'd like to attend but when the phone
didn't ring we knew it was him
Shelley and I have covered first of all
like I said Shelley's grew up in
Dorchester very close to the South
Boston line she went to South Boston
high my entire maternal side is from
South Boston so we would have grown up
knowing learning about Whitey Bulger by
osmosis everybody where we grew up where
we were from knew he was a hoodlum
gangster and a very dangerous guy and it
approximately the same time for
different newspapers we were really
paying attention to him and we're
writing about him and and obviously that
what really made whitey just a
remarkable story is while he was the
most powerful gangster in Boston his
brother Bill was the most powerful
politician in Massachusetts he was the
long-serving
longest-serving president of the state
Senate he had an incredible patronage
network in which he got people's jobs he
got people jobs and with that came an
awful lot of support and for him both
politically but also sort of nobody said
anything about whitey and I was part of
the team in 88 that did a sort of
seminal series on the brothers call it
you know the brothers balls of the
mystique explaining how whitey became
the most powerful gangster in Boston
while his brother was the most powerful
politician but at the heart of the story
was our exposing him in 1988 as an
informant for the FBI
that's why whitey was protected it
wasn't just because of his brother but
it certainly played his brother's role
as a politician played a giant part
but when Shelia there have been other
books written about whitey bulger in
some respects maybe too many many of
them were written by criminal colleagues
of his who basically lie I could we call
the genre of literature lies guy lit
because these guys embellish how tough
and big they are and they also minimize
the amount of serious bad crime they do
so we but as we sat down to map map it
out we said that you know we didn't want
it has been called true crime but we
really sat down to make this a social
history and to explain that a creature
like whitey bulger could only exist in a
certain time and place and so and and
and very peculiar to Boston we don't
really believe that Whitey Bulger could
have existed in New York or Philadelphia
or Chicago or Tucson or LA because of
the of the way that the the ethnic
dynamics of Boston where the the the
Irish were both in control of politics
law enforcement business the Irish
really ran the town and the the the
influence of the Italian mafia was such
that you could the FBI could create a
national policy to go after the Mafia
and use whitey and other criminals from
from an Irish background and say that
they were being used to help get the
Mafia that couldn't only happen in
Boston but as we tried to establish you
know this is a story with great sweep it
begins with Whitey Bulger only came from
South Boston because FDR created public
housing as part of the New Deal and one
of the young congressman who was running
around the country selling the New Deal
for FDR was a guy named John McCormack
who was the representative the
congressman from South Boston and part
of that deal was the first housing
project in New England went into South
Boston and whitey and his family moved
in we kind of chart that whole thing we
chart the sort of the ethnic mix the way
it played out and then also I'd say that
there's the story has different layers
but one of them is this sort of
overweening overwrought sense of loyalty
because in South Boston that there was
an enormous importance placed on loyalty
to you
family to your friends to your neighbors
and to your neighborhood and so when an
FBI I want a guy that became an FBI
agent named John Conlee was able to get
into a position to protect Whitey Bulger
he did it for two reasons
he did it because in if you're a F bi
agent you're all your raises all your
you know your prestige your status
within the bureau is based on creating
informants and Whitey Bulger was seen as
a high you know a very high-level
organized crime figure the top echelon
informant but there was an ulterior
motive there by calling me he wanted to
protect the Bulger family that was very
he was very close to and Billy Bulger
would have been one of his mentor's
helping him become an FBI agent so a lot
of it was this it's this in and you know
I think you all probably know that
Martin Scorsese did a film The Departed
which is loosely based and it very very
loosely based on the whitey character
because of whitey would never get as fat
as Jack Nicholson he's just way to evade
but if that the whole story is that
about sort of the what how this could
only happen in a place like Boston and
Shelley you'd been covering organized
crime I know you had been working in
Providence with the very famous mayor
there who not only was elected as a
criminal but then served jail time and
then got reelected familiar with these
kinds of guys me on Facebook actually oh
my goodness I actually have covered
organized crime in going back to the mid
80s and we had the distinction and in
Boston it was the first sort of a the
first time ever that the FBI tape
recorded a mafia induction ceremony
where mobsters from around New England
gathered at this home in Medford just
outside Boston and they burned holy
cards and pricked their trigger fingers
and vowed to kill anybody you know for
the family and the interesting thing is
you know it's it's as this case you know
they played those tapes you know in
court we got to hear them but that this
was like one of the big major coos of
the FBI in Boston and one of the agents
who had some of the informants who
allowed them you know told them where
this bugging ceremony would be was John
Connolly and so as the story unfolds we
find out that you know he is using
Whitey Bulger and his partner Steve
Flemmi another gangster from Boston as
informants against the Mafia and so we
get to see sort of how these cases that
made heroes of the FBI you know in the
late 80s early 90s and really decimated
the mob here in New England you know it
comes full sweep and now their
relationship with Whitey has sort of
overshadowed all of those successes but
they had you know in bringing down the
Mafia
so it's been an interesting turn of
events and as Kevin said the thing about
Boston is you know the FBI had a
national policy to target the Cosa
Nostra the Mafia and and it made it make
sense in some parts of the country but
in Boston where you know Whitey's gang
was just as powerful if not more so it
didn't really make much sense to use the
head of that gang to target the Italians
and so this it's been a now getting
Garfield cards from mafia bosses from
prison saying what happened well and and
the process of reporting on in
discovering this story must have had
many many oh my goodness moments where
you just completely freaked out with the
different connections that were being
drawn can you talk about a little bit
more father joiner when you found that
in the records and you called the
important well yeah I mean one of the
fascinating things about whitey I mean
he's not a you know he's a fascinating
character he has a very rich history
some of you may know him as one of the
FBI's 10 most wanted for years he was on
the ten most wanted list right next to
Osama bin Laden until he was captured in
Santa Monica California a couple of
years ago in living just a couple of
blocks from the beach I mean it was
quite quite a life he was living as this
retired guy telling people that he was
you know Charlie Gasko from New York but
but one of the things that's interesting
about him is he was a bank robber he had
committed a spring of bank robberies and
he was convicted in 1956 and sent off to
federal prison and because he was
involved in some escape attempts he
ended up at Alcatraz which was you know
the first maximum
security federal prison and it was for
the worst of the worst and much to our
delight as reporters anybody who was
ever done time at Alcatraz their entire
prison file is open for the public to
see you can go to the archives in San
Bruno California and read these very all
of these files letters that he wrote to
his brother while he was in prison you
know what his work record was like while
he was in prison and it was just amazing
to get this glimpse of him as a young
man and one of the things that you know
we've sort of known him in recent yes is
this vicious scary criminal killer and
to see these letters on if you're in
federal prison at least at that time you
were allowed to write to ten people and
why he had a pretty big family so six of
the people or immediate family members
and the other floor were all priests
because who else would a killer right
see right now on but one of the
fascinating things is that on talk about
political connections so well Whitey's
at Alcatraz his brother Billy is at
Boston College Law School and we can see
from the records that Billy had managed
to have father Bob Dryden who later
became congressman Bob Bryan and become
his brother's mentor in prison and that
we saw these letters back and forth that
they're writing and and father drying it
was very big into prison reform and he
really believed white even white he said
oh I'm so tired of being the black sheep
of the family I'm gonna go out and go
straight and you know and he and he
actually mentored him and there was
another part of the story yeah
so he also uses connections to have at
this time
McCormick who Kevin reference became the
Speaker of the House of the US House and
because of the South Boston connections
the Speaker of the House actually well
Whitey's at Alcatraz the family's very
worried about him because they're in
Southie and he's all you know as far as
you can get he's the prison in the
middle of San Francisco Bay they could
speaker McCormick calls the director of
the Bureau of Prisons and says can you
go check on Jimmy Bulger and see whitey
see how he's doing so the director of
the Bureau of Prisons flies to San
Francisco gets on the ferry goes out to
the press
Jimmy how would they treatin you so it's
a very interesting story so so part of
what was fascinating about reading the
book was the debunking of the myth of
Whitey Bulger because I lived in Boston
during a lot of this time and Whitey
Bulger was the gentleman criminal who
was always nice to women and murdering
them so can you talk a bit about the joy
that you got into bunking the myth what
the one thing we tried to show is how
that myth became so widespread in
particularly in South Boston and it
really goes down to we found that when
whitey was a young criminal in the late
40s early 50s he actually had a car in
this neighborhood he grew up on a
housing project hardly anybody had a car
he had a car because he's a criminal and
what he would do is he'd drive around
when he wasn't with his you know Jane
Mansfield look-alike girlfriend Jackie
McAuliffe he would be going prowling
around not looking for criminal
opportunities he was looking for old
ladies and if he saw an old lady
trudging down the street with her
groceries he'd pull over and his
Oldsmobile convertible jump I would open
the door and say come on mrs. mopely get
into the car I'll take you home
and mrs. Moakley happened to be the
mother of that who would become the
congressman Joe Moakley and from South
Boston and so I remember talking in the
80s when I touch all of the old ladies
in the project they would like they
described how people you know they used
to call it stoop talk and that sit out
in the Stoops and the projects and
during a hot summer night and just talk
and every once in a while somebody said
that Jimmy balls he's a scumbag he's a
hoodlum and all the old lady says oh
don't say that about Jimmy Jimmy's a
very nice young man he always stops and
brings me home from the grocery store
and so whitey was very consciously
cultivating this because he knew to be a
criminal and you know you had to have
your neighborhood not turn on you he had
to have them not cooperate with the cops
so it wasn't so much it wasn't with
criminals it was important to be feared
with non criminals it was important to
be liked and whitey worked that and so
and we saw that jelly and I tried to
show that is he spent his entire
criminal career
cultivating this image of him as the
good bad guy the gangster with scruples
but you know gangsters with scruples
don't murder young women and bury them
in the hidden graves but why'd he did
and so he used that and I remember in
the mid 80s I wrote a story about in the
globe based on sort you know DEA agents
Massachusetts State Police and Boston
police people saying that Whitey Bulger
controlled all the drugs anything any
drug movement in Southie he got a cut
off and Billy Bulger his politician
brother who I always got along with who
I always voted for when I lived in South
boss and what my wife came up to me and
hit me in the chest with the finger
saying you're printing lies about my
brother he would never get involved in
drugs and we all knew it was not true
but you know there was also no
conclusive evidence and so one of the
the most satisfying things of his recent
trial his own lawyers got up there and
admitted that he made millions and
millions of dollars from the drug trade
but you know he said his lawyer was it
went to great lengths to say that it was
only cocaine and marijuana he would drew
the line at heroin and angel dust what a
guy I you'd made the comment that this
could only have happened in Boston and
in the in the legal profession there
were people known as triple Eagles who
had gone to a Boston College Prep Boston
College and then Boston College Law
School and they all kind of hung
together and was and it seemed as though
that was also part of the leak I mean
part of the police system part of the
political system and also part of the
reporting system did you see this I mean
where there was a story stifled in any
way within there was a lot of deference
I think it was incredible different I
would compare it though to the deference
shown in the Catholic Church and
actually like I said I was on that team
that spent so many you know months and
more than a year working on the Catholic
Church stuff I saw no difference between
the FBI and the Catholic hierarchy
because what they were doing is that
they were protecting at all cost the
institution so they didn't care what
happened to individuals so the bishops
didn't care the children were being
raped because they just moved the
pedophiles and pedagogues to different
places and let them do it all over again
because they were so obsessed
keeping the institution out of scandal
and the same thing with the FBI the FBI
didn't care that innocent people were
being murdered by Whitey Bulger because
they did not want the scandal to come
out that they had protected Whitey
Bulger and enabled him I mean we have
scenes in the book it's not that the FBI
looked the other way
they actually lied to colleagues within
the bureau there were agents in Oklahoma
City that were trying to nail whitey for
a murder of a legitimate businessmen and
the agents in Boston lied to their
colleagues in Oklahoma City and kept
that guy back on the street so we could
murder people again so to me it's about
the abuse of power and the idea that
institutional corruption it's not
peculiar to the bureau it's not peculiar
to the you know the Archdiocese of
Boston or the Archdiocese of Newark it's
peculiar to power yeah so can you talk a
little bit about some of the individuals
impacted by whitey your book is one of
the unique books that brings out the
victims instead of emphasizing the
glories of the gangster yeah no I think
the one thing that was very important to
us was not to sensationalize the story I
mean this story is so amazing and
there's so many twists and turns and so
many lives impacted but it was important
to us that people understood that this
you know for these families
this was their life and it was very
tragic and whitey went to trial last
summer charged in a big federal
racketeering case with killing 19 people
in the 1970's and 80's and he was
convicted the jury found that he was
guilty of 11 of those murders they could
not reach an agreement on one and the
others they just felt that the
government had failed to prove it but
was so you know difficult for these
families is for years there was a lot of
fear and so even people who suspected
whitey of killing had really nowhere to
go because what was happening is people
would go to the FBI to complain and and
why do you would find out about it and
some of the murders were instances where
other people who went to inform against
ye not knowing that he was the biggest
informative
all would be killed so and many of these
people as Kevin said you know some of
these victims were buried in secret
graves and the story really did not
begin to fully unfold its Hill YT went
on the run
in 1995 whitey was indicted in Boston
and on a racketeering charge and just
weeks before the indictment the FBI
agent who was then retired warned him to
run and so he took off and while he was
on the run basically what happened is
you know the-the-the
his his co-defendants who are arrested
you know began filing motions in court
to find out if there are any informants
involved in the case and the FBI was
forced to publicly admit that yes what
the globe had reported in 1988 yes it is
true whitey was an informant and some of
his friends just couldn't believe this
and one of the things that we found most
amazing is so the Mafia
they never suspect they just couldn't
believe that he would be an informant
they couldn't believe that what the FBI
would be in bed with such a vicious guy
the FBI actually used him as a freelance
hit man you would do jobs in the
bathroom in the Mafia for the Mafia so
they were astounded and so what happened
as many of his closest associates felt
betrayed and they caught and they were
also facing indictment themselves and
they cut deals and there's been a lot of
criticism of the deals that were cut but
it was the deals that were cut that
allowed some of these people to go free
early which is a travesty but it also
they led investigators to the secret
graves so they started digging up bodies
around Boston of people who had vanished
you know in the 70s and in the 80s and
and there were six you know victims who
were recovered and so for the families
who sat through this you know eight week
trial last summer it was so important to
them to be able to look whitey in the in
the eye and see him on trial they have
to tell you you know after all of the
years of people being so terrified of
him around Southie and so intimidated I
think there was a real I don't believe
in the word closure I don't think any
victim ever has closure I don't know why
the media ever uses such a word but I
think the
we felt a little bit empowered to
finally see him as this old man sitting
there in trial you know and having his
his his day you know in court finally
being brought to justice and I also
think it was so amazing to see some of
these victims families get up on the
witness stand and look him in the eye
people who would have been too afraid to
do that when he was walking the streets
but my favorite part of is that when we
document in the book that whitey is an
out-and-out racist and a misogynist and
he fought like hell to get the first
judge removed from the case and the next
judge that came in was a black woman
Denise Casper so every day he had to
look up at this you know remarkably
educated erudite very nice African
America judge and she did a hell of a
job and the last words in his case were
spoken by Neely's Kasper and she looked
at him and she made remarkable talk
about you know we had gone through a lot
in Boston with you know the low of the
Marathon bombing the high of the Red Sox
winning it and she said you know it's
been a traumatic year and a triumphant
year for our city but you sir do not
represent our city some people have
tried to create you as this myth of
Boston you do not represent our city and
I've sitting there and with shelley's in
the courtroom I was just saying you go
girl
Denise Casper she was great Sir John
Connolly sort of emerges as a very
interesting figure I heard and
interviewed where he was arguing that
the deal that the FBI cut with Whitey
Bulger and Kevin weeks was that they
could commit any crime other than murder
was I guess what Kevin weeks was saying
and Connolly misty Fleming and so so so
then Connolly was saying no that wasn't
what the deal was but Connolly now is
serving jail time and a harsher jail
sentence than Kevin weeks right who
actually killed people you know John
Connolly he caused people to die and he
is now serving a 40 year prison term
down in Miami this is the FBI agent who
orchestrated but really it
a travesty because he has become the
scapegoat for everything the FBI did
wrong there were other agents who I mean
if you if you read the book you'll see
that there was a period of time when
whitey was an FBI informant where and
Steve Flemmi was where the two of them
are sitting down for these cozy dinners
with the FBI agents they're swapping
Christmas gifts they're hey yeah they
would they treated him like he was a
partner not an ad you know not a
criminal and so there were eight you
know there was testimony that other
agents took bribes and got money and you
know one agent who was a supervisor and
and you know we believe caused at least
one one or two murders he had immunity
from prosecution
and never served the day and there's
something wrong when you see that agent
get up on the stand with immunity and we
think they were worse than the gangsters
you know that certainly he was and and
he was crying and sobbing about how
sorry he is and how he you know he now
works at a soup kitchen so everybody
feels better about that right but the I
mean the FBI the Justice Department that
this was always about minimizing the
extent of corruption you know recognized
right now the FBI and the Justice
Department want people 50 years from now
to say oh yeah there was a bad case but
only one agent went to prison one of the
things we show in the book had judge
mark Wolfe who was one of the real
heroes few heroes in this case who made
this thing come up get public he
identified a dozen FBI agents and
supervisors who he believed could be
charged with crimes but the FBI let I
mean the Justice Department led
everything the statute of limitations
run on thing there was an agent who
called me at the globe and said I'd be
murdered if we reported that Whitey was
an informant nothing ever happened to
him there was an agent one of the most
shocking things that is in the book and
it doesn't take up a lot of room but
Steve Flemmi in one of his reports that
we went over told the FBI
I'm sorry told the State Police and the
Drug Enforcement Administration that
John Newton an FBI agent who got in
trouble for stealing the the antlers at
the Unabomber cabin up in Montana I
think John's excuse was they were out in
the trash I know whenever I throw away
an was I put them on the trash but
anyway John Newton
Steve Flemmi said gave him in whitey
balls are 40 pounds of c-4 explosive
which then they shipped to the IRA and
presumably the Irish Republican Army
used this attacks on military and police
people throughout the United Kingdom and
when Shelley called John Newton and said
John here's the his his the we want your
side of this this is what the allegation
is he was I didn't do that that's not
true and then Shelley's follow-up was
well what did you what did you tell your
supervisors or anybody else from the
Justice Department questions you about
the single I was never questioned about
this although later I was told he lied
about this something else she put those
antlers on so you two are actually the
first people I've ever heard referred to
Steve Flemmi as Steve Flemmi instead of
Steve the rifleman Flemmi can you talk a
little bit about Steve the rifleman
Flemmi well Steve the rifleman Flemmi
actually earned that nickname because he
was on yeah he was a paratrooper he was
with the 187th em1 in Korea and that's
where he got the name but you know on
the streets of Boston people assumed
that name came from somewhere else
because he was he was a known killer but
one of the interesting things for me
when you talk about something being
close to home my father was a
paratrooper in the same combat unit and
had served in Korea and did not know
Steve Flemmi when they were in the
service but my father who passed away a
few years ago years ago he's raising
money for the Korean War Memorial in
Washington and he meets Steve Flemmi and
tells him oh we have this group we get
together with our wives around the
country in fact they came to Scottsdale
Arizona one weekend and we travel we buy
wives and our girlfriends come we all
get together and and Steve join the
group and and I'm writing about him and
he's you know a suspect and drug dealing
and all these things and meanwhile he's
going to these like airborne retreats on
weekends around the country and it was
feeling I'm like dad this guy's like
really bad there's a lot of Murphy's in
Boston I sure hope he doesn't know your
daughter is you know
yeah kind of scary and so he so
eventually he figured out you know who I
was and I was concerned that they were
getting a little close but it was funny
because of my my father knew who he was
I mean I kind of had this inside you
know information and I found out that on
the 50th anniversary of the em1 there
was this huge celebration in Washington
and the New England the group from New
England led the parade in general was
more less moral it was there at the
dinner and Steve Flemmi showed up at
this dinner with all these like you know
the high ranking officials in Washington
with his good buddy Jimmy Bulger whitey
yeah they were actually there and they
and they took photos of um whitey with
this Medal of Honor winner and whitey
was in this white suit and when whitey
went on the run the FBI what a shock
didn't have very many photos of him and
so they were looking for photos to put
out to people you know when he was
wanted and one of the photos they
tracked down was this photo from the the
everyone celebration that was one of the
pitches they cut the middle of won a
winner out I'm sure he was happy about
that oh my goodness
and then the IRA gun-running Fiasco
Kevin did you come across that because
you did a lot of work on Northern
Ireland and the peace accord so I mean I
knew you dig at it from both sides yeah
I did I got a lot of stuff in Ireland
from people it was interesting because
um and I mean we knew that that that
mission went to the IRA and was seized
by the Irish Navy and it was the biggest
gun-running mission out of the United
States during the whole troubles and we
knew that Bulger was involved and even
though he was not charged with it
because the guy that really ran at
Patton II was a Confederate he was and
Patton II was Shelley and I've known for
years a career criminal
I reformed no nope yes he means from
writing yes
well Patni lived he lived on coal my
building so but uh when I was after that
I mean it wonder that I was in 1997 I
knew I was over there program I was
living in Ireland covering the peace
process full-time but there's still a
lot of trouble going on and I remember
there was a guy killed and he was
married to this dog married to the niece
of Gerry Adams ahead of Schenn Fame
which is the political wing of the IRA
and I went to cover the funeral in place
called turf lodge in West Belfast which
is a very can i what was the year of the
IRA gun fiasco with whitey
it would have been 84 was the actual
field misses so now we're going 13 years
forward yeah
and now white he's on the run by this
time and a friend of mine who I knew
came up to me and said will you talk to
so-and-so and as soon as he said it I
knew who he was the nickname of this guy
he was he was the IRA commander in that
area and he had also been the IRA
commander during the hunger strikes in
the in 1981 he said he wants to talk to
you ok and this is why the funeral
cortege worth tens of thousands people
lined up so I go up to that and I went
and put my hand out and he ignored me
and he just said he said is Whitey
Bulger at OU and I said what yeah I said
yeah that was in the paper like that he
goes that's not what I asked you is he a
tout that's what they call an informer
I said yeah yes and that was all he
wanted to talk about at that point and I
always wondered if the I you know why
he'd you know portrayed himself as a big
supporter of the IRA but if the IRA you
can't be a you know it's like being a
little pregnant you can't be a little
Informer the IRA would have put him in a
chair and they would have got
information out of him one way or
another I always thought that that that
was he's lucky he does that and that's
when a lot when he took off a lot of
people said he would he was in Ireland
and the FBI went to Ireland many many
times to look for him and I knew that's
the last place he would go because he
knew first of all he would have been
found out the Irish love talking with
people they would have been on him like
that but if the IRA ever found him he
knew exactly what was going to happen
but a friend of mine who works
for the goddess Chicana he actually on
more than one occasion he picked up FBI
agents who were going over to supposedly
look for whitey in Ireland and one day
he came to Boston just on holiday and I
took him out for a pint and was just
sitting there and I said Joe that FBI
guys are they do they ever ever like
really serious leads when they go
looking for him like and particularly in
the West and he said mmm no but they
always have their clubs so so right he
failed at sending guns to the IRA and
then he also failed at going into the
high Ally business venture - it sounds I
mean part of the debunking of the Whitey
Bulger myth that I think your book did
really successfully was show what a
loser he was on so many different levels
so can you talk a bit about the high
Ally not only is it one of the best
words for crossword puzzles but it also
was a legitimate business in Boston yeah
well that was a very very sad case
because Roger wheeler who was who owned
world highlight and was presidents of
telex a president of telex he was shot
to death outside a Country Club in Tulsa
back in 1981 and the the murder was it
was really orchestrated by whitey
Bulger's gang and it was part of an
attempt they apparently one of the
former the former president of the
company had been skimming money and he
in the company had been sold Roger
wheeler bought it legitimate businessman
you know employed a lot of people in the
Tulsa area he suspected that the company
somebody was embezzling so they killed
him as a plot of a plot to take over the
company and to avoid indictment and then
there were subsequent murders to cover
up the first murder and so the FBI in in
Tulsa was and the Tulsa Police were
aggressively trying to solve the murder
and they are sending you know we see
these these all came out in court
they're sending memos to the FBI in
Boston saying hey we're hearing that the
you know the family and other people in
the company believe this murder may have
something to do
with the Winter Hill Gang the name of
white his gang back from Boston and who
did they assign to like start looking
but John Connelly the FBI agent who's
Whitey's handler and the other thing
they did is they never disclosed to the
Tulsa Police that whitey was an
informant and so you know they're you
know and and there didn't share all
their information with Tulsa so
eventually they there were a number of
murders connected to this and one down
in Florida and two more in Boston and
they finally bring Bulger and his
sidekick Steve Flemmi who's also
involved in the murder in to interview
them at the FBI well they they refused
to be interviewed unless it was together
they refused to do it in the FBI offices
so they were really dictating terms so
the sad thing though was during the
trial to see the wheeler family come in
and you know take the stand and they're
very angry at the government because
they you know when it was finally
revealed all these behind-the-scenes
shenanigans that went on and they sued
they filed a wrongful death suit against
the government like many of these
families did families of victims but
what the government did is if you want
to sue the federal government in a
wrongful death case a Federal Tort claim
you have to file your claim within two
years of being wronged or within two
years of when a reasonable person would
have known they had a case and what they
did is they had all the government
argued you're right the FBI was liable
but you should have known sooner and you
should have filed sooner and they won
and a lot of these cases were dismissed
on those grounds so there's a lot of
bitterness you know by the families that
not only were they victims but then they
were screwed by the government hmm
what's your favorite part of the Whitey
Bulger story the end
I am so sick of this guy so the the
jailbreak isn't imminent
he's what 82 right 94 years old yes I
think what I found really fascinating
was I mean it I agree with Kevin my
favorite part was seeing him walk away
in handcuffs to me the saddest thing
would have been if he that there were a
lot of people who never thought he would
be caught and they were afraid he would
sort of ride off into the sunset and
that would be the end of it so I think
to have him caught it was so important
in fact well he was on the run and one
of the FBI's 10 most wanted he did come
to Arizona and Nevada to buy guns he
stockpiled 30 guns he bought well he was
one of the FBI's 10 most wanted and when
they arrested him and he also used the
identity of a number of false IDs he had
but he would what he did out in Santa
Monica is he would look for homeless
people and people that kind of looked
like him and he would buy their
identities from them and he paid one man
from Arizona I think two hundred dollars
for his ID and the guy threw in his
Costco membership a couple of months ago
after after the trial wanted wet his
lawyer was giving a speech to a bunch of
defense attorneys in Boston and at one
point which is kind of bizarre the
lawyer talked about how white he
fantasized about you know choking me
until he could see the light go out of
my eyes so I wrote a column saying isn't
so that's not particularly original as
my wife would say if you want to
strangle me get in line
oh my so um my favorite story was when
whitey bulger won the Massachusetts
lottery I mean here we have his brother
as the Prez go to Senate and then went
on to be the head of the UMass system
and then we have this criminal that's on
the lam and then he won the Boston
Lottery I mean the hostages a lot of it
wasn't insane yeah he did and and
there's some you know question I mean
when he was on the run and they seized
them what was left of his lottery
winnings they you know there were
different versions of what really
happened but it was actually you know
the brother of one of his associates who
won but then they claimed that it was oh
well the deal was if he won we would
split the ticket so many ways and it
really was an attempt to have legitimate
income to make it look like he had a
legitimate income it was really a you
know a way of laundering money so the
the the government did seize that when
he fled they also found eight hundred
and twenty-two thousand dollars in cash
stuffed in the wall of his Santa Monica
apartment after he'd been on the run for
16 years and they found all these guns
in the walls and but it's amazing
because he was such a master at
manipulation and people said if he
wanted you to like him his friend said
you would like him he would be charming
and engaging and he had so charmed his
neighbor's in Santa Monica that some of
them continued to write to him even
though they found all these guns in the
wall it you know they're like yeah but
you know he was he would never use them
and he was just you know they find it
hard to believe they say the guy we knew
was Charlie Gasko we don't know that
Whitey Bulger guy one of the in trying
to Capra we what we try to say is why he
is a man of contradictions and one of
the I think the most chilling
contradictions about him is he's there's
several murders in which he was charged
was shooting somebody in the head and
then going up and taking a nap while his
you know his lessers buried those bodies
and hidden graves and yet Shelley found
when she went out to Louisiana and found
this Cajun family that he had befriended
and spent a lot while he was on the run
they had to put a dog down and whitey
said well he thought that shooting it
would be more humane when the guy went
to shoot the dog what he turned away he
couldn't watch it and when after the
report of the the gun shot wide he began
to weep so he could weep over a dog and
sleep over a human being so that's weird
yes so we have about 20 minutes left so
if you've got questions there are
there's a microphone right here this is
being taped and broadcast on c-span so
make sure that you clearly enunciate
your question and yes I have a question
while you were doing all this
investigative writing did you ever
personally feel threatened how did they
try to stop you from disclosing all this
the only serious threat I got was from
the FBI when they called me and said
that if we wrote that whitey was an
informant he'd think nothing of killing
me and I was living with my wife in
South Boston at the time I was very
vulnerable so eventually we came to the
conclusion that the FBI there's a formal
process that they would have to notify
me or anybody who would be threatened
with murder like that and they didn't do
that so we came to the conclusion that
this was really just an attempt to
intimidate the globe from not publishing
that so but just to be sure right before
we published that my wife and I moved
from South Boston this is so Boston we
moved nine stops down the transit we
went from like Southie to Harvard Square
as I said he'll never find us a table at
square
and we you know so we lived there for a
couple of weeks until Jack O'Malley a
very good Massachusetts a cop had very
good a very good informant within the
Bulger group or on the fringes of it and
he reported that whitey wasn't mad about
the whole disclosure man being in a
former because he said nobody would
believe it in fact we found a report in
which he said that the FBI said do we
need to take you off the street and he
said nobody will believe it's just the
globe going after my brother that's how
he portrayed it but so my wife and I
moved back into Southie but and and to
be honest we only lived there a couple
more years my wife never felt
comfortable in there but that had to do
with as much with people letting their
dogs poop all over the sidewalk says
why'd he be in down the street one thing
I would say is in writing this book one
of the most fascinating things we whitey
refused to to talk to us he refused to
know we wrote to him I'm a number of
times and he wouldn't write back to us
but he did write with a friend who had
served time with him in Alcatraz who
shared and letters with us and when we
read these letters it was amazing to see
what you know I mean whitey may have a
lot of problems but one of them is not
self-esteem
he's a very high opinion of himself but
he also the things he said about us he
told his friend don't talk to Shelly and
Kevin that I was a traitor I said he
wants to turn the clock back and pay
Kevin a visit and when I read the
letters I was like maybe I was a little
naive years ago I wasn't really afraid
but now I'm really happy he's isn't the
prison down the street yes why do you
think it took the FBI so long to start
with the advertising program that
eventually it does first one of the
things we show in the book is the first
two years they weren't looking for him
because they didn't want to find him it
wasn't until the FBI created a there was
just a blatant conflict of interest that
when whitey took off
the FBI has signed the search for him to
the very organized crime squad that he
had corrupted so they were the last
people that had a vested interest in
finding him and one of the things we
showed in the book is that it was not
until you
multi-agency task force and particularly
when they brought the US Marshals that's
what they do they find bad guys and
wasn't until that happened but it was
interesting because the task force which
was at some point you know a dozen
agents from oh it wasn't it when they
finally did catch him it was an FBI
agent named Phil Torres and they who was
not from Boston crucial he was from
Cleveland and then the other guy named
Neal Sullivan who was a deputy US
Marshal they kind of found him on their
own but that's my view I'm a little more
opinion as a columnist I can be a little
more opinionated but I don't believe the
FBI wanted to find him and by the time
they did want to find him the trail had
gone cold and white he was living in a
rent-controlled apartment two blocks
from the water in Santa Monica yes one
of the most interesting parts about the
book to me was how it exposed how
interconnected and integrated you know
the political system the business
establishment and the criminal
organizations in America are how they're
like you know sort of branches and I
wondered how learning about that and
sort of studying that how you would how
that affects the way you view
contemporary things in America well I'm
a reporter and he's a columnist somewhat
gonna let him give his opinion well I it
goes back to what I I'm only I'd be
repeating myself that I think that this
this is a story at the end of the day
about institutional corruption and all
institutions are capable of corruption I
just think the problem with the FBI
is that nobody's head rolls I think the
FBI was founded in the image of one of
the most corrupt public officials in the
history of this Republic and that's j
edgar Hoover so you begin with that
premise but I mean to this day the FBI
insists on interviewing so if if they
wanted to interview with me they said
okay show up at this appointed time and
I'll say I want to bring a tape recorder
in this no no tape recorders it's gonna
be two agents one asking questions and
writing and writing it down so it's your
word against theirs that's that to me is
corrupt and the reality is everybody in
Washington is afraid of those guys so
nothing ever chain
and I to this day I think the FBI needs
a huge institutional enema
and they're not going to get it because
everybody in Washington is very
deferential to them one thing I would
say though is that there were some
heroes in this book I mean they're in
this whole saga and there were FBI
agents who really wanted him and really
worked hard to find him so I mean I
wouldn't paint everybody with a broad
brush I'm not saying everybody would but
I'm saying they are not reformed to the
extent they need but I just you know I
do think that I don't want to leave it
that we didn't think there were people
who did good work here from that agency
okay yes yeah my mom's cousin worked for
whitey and what's her name his name his
name was David Ryan and he held up an
armored truck and he got caught and then
he went into witness protection
and he was sent to Tennessee he was in a
beautiful yeah was he he was the
informant he was the informant yeah they
try to portray check them by saying he
got jammed up yeah we have to talk
I covered this case oh yeah I'm the
genealogist and the family so I've been
trying to get one I have a lot of
material though I can send you you know
I think I was still alive but I know
he's gone so he got really obese in
Tennessee
anyway so the question I had one of the
stories I heard from his brother and
I've always wondered if this is urban
legend or if this is the truth it was
this horrific story about how whitey and
his men would attack little girls on the
way to school and they would be raped I
know that sound kind of imagine oh if
you if you read the I mean what you know
what there's there's a book that was
written that was largely exaggerated by
one of someone who pretended to be
closer to whitey than he really was and
and that story sort of you know that
wasn't white he was on the run but it's
a fact you know when you watch the movie
departed and they have that really
creepy scene with Jack Nicholson is
talking leering at the young girl I'm
making really you know crude remarks
whitey like young girls why do you like
young women
why he was a real womanizer even though
there were two you know primary women in
his life the one that he lived with for
like 30 years while he was carrying on
an affair with another one for like 20 I
mean he was a womanizer but but I don't
we never found anything to support you
know I mean unless you statutory rape I
think he had girls as young as 15 16
years old and what he would do though
why he wasn't a guy that would go snatch
someone off the street whitey was a guy
who would buy the family with money and
there was one case where he bought a
triple-decker for the girl's mother
because he was sleeping with the
daughter okay so he was not a nice guy
but how was he finally captured it was a
great story and it's something that it
talked about you know truth being
stranger than fiction
there was a woman miss Iceland 1974 any
of you might remember the old nods emic
commercials take it off take it all off
well she was one of the blondes you know
in the commercial and she lived across
the street from them in Iceland you know
when it's dark from you know much of the
day and many of those people will come
and they'll stay in California or other
places for months at a time and so she
for months at a time would live across
the street from them in Santa Monica and
it was a stray cat that got white he
captured because Whitey's girlfriend
Kathy who was living with him loved the
animals absolutely loved them and she
used to feed these stray cats in the
neighborhood and Miss Iceland
notice this and thought what a lovely
woman and became friendly with them but
she didn't much like whitey he was very
opinionated a little bit nasty sometimes
they would talk politics and he was very
opinionated about what he believed and
so she they made an impression so she's
sitting home in her house and Reykjavik
and sees the FBI launched a new campaign
to find him where they were targeting
the girlfriend thinking why do you look
very much like half my relatives you
know he's like the great here in the
Irish face and so they were having
trouble finding him but they really
focused on her and they launched a
campaign where they they had these um
public service announcements have you
seen these people and they ran them and
you know
daytime television but CNN wrote about
did a segment on the new campaign and on
Ibiza and dota are sitting in Reykjavik
saw them and recognize them as her
neighbors in Santa Monica and so she
called the FBI and they sent a couple of
agents out who interviewed the manager
of the apartment who also lived in the
apartment next to them and showed him
the photos and you and he was like oh my
god those are my neighbors and they said
are you sure and he said yes and they
said will you go knock on the door and
lure him out and he said no I might talk
to Charlie White he's done so that's how
you know he actually later complained in
one of the letters that he wrote a cat
got me capture can't make that up right
and that's just amazing the story can't
be made up I mean it just goes on and on
which is one of the things that your
book really beautifully captures yes we
lived in the Boston area for around 20
years and I was always interested in the
fact that Billy just seemed to skate
he was never tainted with anything that
you ever heard or read about his brother
how did that happen
well there is as I mentioned the
deference that was shown in South Boston
almost every family would have what you
would call a black sheep and I think
there was this feeling that you you know
those who live in glass houses shouldn't
throw stones the other thing you have to
remember is that there wasn't much in in
the public domain about whitey it was
all whisper it was stuff he didn't talk
about that all I mean I remember you
know as a kid in my teens Biff I would
mention that name people would look at
you're not supposed to talk about that
but you know the other thing is Billy I
mean I did more stuff after the try
talking about I I mean we view Billy is
sort of an enabler Billy and that
invested so much time and political
influence and genuine love he cared
about his brother here it to this day he
does and got him out of the out of
prison early got out you get a 20 year
sentence for bank robbery got out after
nine and I think Billy really believed
he was going to go straight and when
whitey didn't I think Billy was in a lot
of denial about how bad is brought
was but the other thing is you have to
understand and all those twenty thirty
years that Billy's a powerful politician
he's getting so and so hired he's
getting that guy hired you know our
Transit Authority in the Boston ears
called the MBTA and not for nothing is
it called mr. Bulger's Transit Authority
because he got people jobs and so that
if Billy Bulger was your patron and he
got you a job you're not gonna go down
the barroom and said his brother white
he's a scumbag that isn't how it works
and particularly in South Boston people
don't do that they don't point fingers
it oh your cousin's a bank robber
because you know his cousin might be a
bank robber something we always say you
know in those families it you know
everybody has one or two cousins that
they sell uh my god there we go so
that's part of it so where is Billy
Bulger now what's what's the where is he
he still visits
well when whitey was in jail awaiting
trial he continued to visit him he did
not attend the trial at all but we think
it was really that he did not want to
deal with the media gauntlet I mean it
was very highly you know covered trial
highly publicized his children though
would attend the trial
like his daughters and sons so he is he
still the head of the UMass system oh no
he was a few questions I met job energy
remember but before Mitt Romney was you
know a presidential candidate he was
governor of Massachusetts and he
actually pressured Billy to resign and
it was after we had written a story I
heard a story that Billy was called
before a federal grand jury and
questioned about whether he had ever had
any contact with whitey while he was on
the run and someone leaked me this
testimony that showed that yes in fact
well Billy was president of the
Massachusetts Senate and whitey was a
fugitive there was a pre-arranged phone
call where he called his brother saying
you know what should I do you know
should I surrender what do you think and
Billy said that he did not think it
would be in his best interest to do so
and that didn't go over really well in
Massachusetts you know people felt that
he had his allegiance was to his brother
and some people would say hey you know
that's his brother and it wasn't his job
to condemn and Letta find him but I
think people felt like he was caught
Billy was questioned in front of a
congressional committee in 2003 about
this and what he knew and when he knew
it and Billy who was very articulate and
bright just it came across as very
evasive and so there was a lot of
pressure for him to resign his job okay
yeah
are there more whitey Bulger's out there
today and how his organized crime of
this country changed over the last 5-10
years well take the second part of that
first I mean the mafia is a shell of
what it used to be I mean basically all
they have a sports book and New York
some extortion some but in Boston it's
like it's almost pathetic what they are
and the the organized crime I would say
we don't recognize what organized it be
different ethnic groups that have you
know that that don't have long histories
in the country generally targeting their
own people and the authorities don't
have the language skills to get in there
sort of like the where the black hand
became the mafia you couldn't you
couldn't infiltrate that in the you know
teens early 20s or anything like that
the set I'm sorry the first part of the
question was are there more whitey
Bulger's yeah we actually wrote about
there was a guy that was very easy for
he was a mafia guy but he he was
protected by the FBI and the way I know
but there was the Massachusetts a police
who again did some of the best work and
going after whitey they were trying to
target this guy his name is mark Rosetti
and in fact before they launched the
investigate and put the bug up on him
they called an FBI supervisor and said
listen courtesy we're going after
Rosetti and we believe he's your guy
meaning he's your informant no no no
he's not our guy not at all I think okay
just want to give you a heads up about
so first conversation when they turn on
the bug is Rosetti mark Rosetti talking
to his FBI handler and so they do their
invocation oh I think the State Police
are coming out to be you got to help me
and so they finally do
the case on them and they and they like
you know they lock him up and now he's
doing 12 years for all sorts of crimes
so that FBI supervisor who had been
given the heads-up calls this state cop
who I know and says hey that was a great
pinch you guys made do you want to roll
them together in the stick
roll them we're gonna put him in prison
but I gotta use him as an informant just
because you guys did we're not gonna use
him and he says they say cop goes you do
know he's killed six people and the FBI
guy says well we know of only one so it
I don't think you could ever be on the
scale of Balzer but I and I don't want
to just blame the FBI they're not the
only law enforcement agency that makes
deals with Devils you got to do it but
it the problem is who supervises this
now we went out after that the Whitey
Bulger thing came out they said oh this
will never happen again
the us are always be an assistant US
attorney checking on these informants so
I called the US attorney I said who's
checking on mark Rosetti who was it was
the assistant US attorney we can't tell
you and and and congressmen like Steve
Lynch Chuck Grassley from Iowa they've
been trying to get answers for this the
FBI just won't tell them if they don't
have to so so so we'll look forward to
reading your next book on the next major
criminal figure but immediately
following this session the authors will
be autographing books at the U a
bookstore tent sponsored by you a
bookstore fabulous book highly
recommended books are available for
purchase at the signing area last but
not least if you are in during the
festival please become a friend of the
festival your tax-deductible donation
allows us to offer festival programming
free of charge to the public and to
support literacy programs in the
community you may learn more at the
friend of the festival booths at the
mall or online in our website thank you
very much thank you
he's good and true they know what
someone told me to sound like state
criminal yeah can you text it to me